well as protests over public health
measures persist some provinces are
easing restrictions so starting today
vaccine passports are no longer required
in saskatchewan quebec gyms spas and
other venues are reopening at half
capacity meanwhile alberta dropping
masks in schools still there's no clear
consensus on canada's next steps with
more on this conversation let's bring in
our infectious diseases specialist dr
isaac vogosh doctor great to see you
yeah good to see you as well anthony so
in many provinces as you know there are
easing restrictions some provinces
lifting restrictions all together is it
safe to assume that we are at the point
that we can go into that next phase
where we can live with covet and what
does that mean for you
right i mean i for one thing i think
we've been living with covet for two
years sometimes better than others but
uh but i think we have to acknowledge
that we obviously have to find a way to
move forward while it while appreciating
that this virus isn't going to go away
on the other hand too we have to ensure
that this virus doesn't impact canadian
society and cause the significant
morbidity and mortality that it has in
prior waves so that might include you
know having additional measures that
we've seen but of course when the public
health threat starts to abate your
policy has to align with the current
public health threat and the best
available science and that means it's
totally okay to start lifting some of
these measures here's something nobody
wants to talk about kovid's not going
anywhere there will be more waves there
will be more variants obviously we hope
with vaccination and recovery from prior
infection that we have good community
immunity and good community protection
so that these waves don't uh impact us
as they have in the past but you know
there might be a time where people
places that have abandoned mass mandates
might need to reconsider that i think it
would be
terrible to start shutting down schools
and businesses again but uh some light
touch policies like masking may need to
be reproduced well into the future if
things don't go the way we want it to go
i want to get more into that in a moment
but as we sort of approach this next
step and and i sense caution in your
tone a little bit but at the same time
are we at the point now when we are just
frankly dealing with a different kind of
threat and that we need to see public
health through a wider lens
we absolutely do i mean we absolutely do
it's it's extremely important to
recognize not just a singular focus on
the virus but of course all other other
facets of society but you can't ignore
the virus right we can't bury our head
in the sand and pretend this doesn't
exist right it's not every day that you
know 25 to 30 percent of your hospital
admissions are related to one single
cause so i think it's extremely
important that we obviously not ignore
what can be a significant public health
threat and which has been a significant
public health threat but also
acknowledge that we do have the tools to
keep this at bay and to prevent this
from impacting us here in canada as
significantly as it has i listen we're
walking a bit of a tight rope now
between pandemic to what we might
consider as endemic we're in this
transitionary period i think we'll see
some you know turbulence along the way
but eventually we'll get there
now the good and the bad of the last
phase if you will with omicron is that
the numbers
went sky high in a lot of cases as we
saw in many other countries as well so
whipped through this country many ways
but then there was a sharp drop it there
wasn't while there's a strain on the
health care system there's no question
it didn't overwhelm it at least you know
in comparison but given that and i want
to ask you of the power of
infection recovered immunity
otherwise known as natural immunity how
important is that
given this next phase
yeah you obviously can't ignore
that people who have been infected and
have recovered from illness have some
degree of immunity for some period of
time uh it looks like that might have
been stronger with prior variance
compared to
this variant but again we're learning as
we as we go along there's some clues
that recovery from omicron might not
people might not mount the same degree
of an immune response uh versus prior
variance but they still do and of course
that has to count for something we have
to appreciate that that i think the
other important thing to recognize too
is in the studies that occurred
pre-omicron uh well well certainly
people who have recovered from infection
have some degree of benefit and
protection for some period of time it
looks like there's more robust
protection from vaccination more durable
and long-lasting protection especially
against severe illness and there are
some studies pointing in that direction
so while while both are important um
vaccination is still an extremely
important tool and i think people who
haven't been vaccinated should still
strongly consider getting vaccinated
yeah there's no question i know we have
about 30 seconds i want to talk are we
at the point now where we can have and
focus on the targeted intervention the
testing of high priority groups um you
know not necessarily boosting uh 18 plus
for example but focusing on the high
risk high-risk groups in our society
yes uh we certainly can focus on that
but i think it's also important to
acknowledge that there is still
uncertainty as the road moves forward
and as we move forward with with covet
there are knowns and unknowns that lie
ahead we have to be able to adapt to
whatever comes our way and we can kind
of predict what comes our way as well
well we continue to adapt every day for
the past my goodness we're now in the
third year lots going on we appreciate
all your time and your insight
everything that you do dr isaac bogage
thank you sir
you all have a great day